my national security team and i have
been closely monitoring the situation on
the ground in afghanistan
and moving quickly to execute the plans
we had put in place
to respond to every constituency
including and contingency
including the rapid collapse we're
seeing now
i'll speak more in a moment about the
specific steps we're taking
but i want to remind everyone how we got
here
and what america's interests are in
afghanistan
we went to afghanistan almost 20 years
ago
with clear goals
get those who attacked us on september
11 2001
and
make sure al qaeda could not use
afghanistan as a base from which to
attack us again
we did that
we severely degraded al-qaeda in
afghanistan
we never gave up the hunt for osama bin
laden and we got him
that was a decade ago
our mission in afghanistan was never
supposed to have been nation-building
it was never supposed to be creating a
unified centralized democracy
our only vital national interest in
afghanistan remains today what has
always been
preventing a terrorist attack on
america's homeland
i've argued for many years that our
mission should be narrowly focused on
counter-terrorism not
counter-insurgency or nation-building
that's why i opposed the surge
when it was proposed in 2009 when i was
vice president
and that's why as president i'm adamant
we focus on the threats we face today in
2021 not yesterday's threats
today
the terrorist threat has metastasized
well beyond afghanistan
al-shabaab in somalia
al-qaeda in the arabian peninsula
al-nusra in syria
isis attempting to create a caliphate in
syria and iraq
and establishing affiliates in multiple
countries
in africa and asia
these threats warrant our attention
and our resources
we conduct effective counterterrorism
missions against terrorist groups and
multiple countries
where we don't have permanent military
presence
if necessary
we'll do the same in afghanistan
we've developed counterterrorism over
the horizon capability
that will allow us to keep our eyes
firmly fixed on the direct threats to
the united states and the region
and act quickly and decisively if needed
you